[Music]
hi thanks for coming in checking out
chess openings abridged this is gonna be
a short video series where we go over
the chess openings in a shorter amount
of time taking over Jonathan trounces
legacy today we're gonna be going over
the Sicilian defense the dragon
variation in the Yugoslav attack we're
gonna go over the main line and get
cement of the main attacking ideas for
both sides so with it being the Sicilian
defense we first start with E for c5
following the main lines we end up
playing Knight of 3 d6 and then d4 and
through best practice white gives up a
center pawn in order to get piece
activity we play Knight of 6 and Knight
c3 to defend our a pawn and then what
characterizes it as the Dragon is this
move g6 here there are other
alternatives black has such as a6 the
NIE Dorf
there's also east 6 the shivahn again
you have the classical with nice e6 but
again we're just gonna be focusing on
the dragon the next move is Bishop e3
and this is what it helps turn it into
the Yugoslavia attack we want to make
sure all of our pieces are being
developed and Bishop e3 gets our dark
square Bishop out we play Bishop g7 to
Fein kettle or King side Bishop and then
we play f3 we play off 3 to stop the
move Knight g4 the reason we don't need
to play off 3 right away is because if
we go back and black plays Knight g4 in
this position it's actually a big-time
blunder
we have Bishop b5 check and black ends
up losing a piece if he ends up going
Bishop to d7 we can end up taking on g4
with the Queen because our Bishop is
pinning blacks Bishop if they block with
the night we take with our knight and
black runs into a fork and loses the
exchange so black can't play Knight g4
right away
back to our position after f3 black
castles Queen d2 we're looking to castle
on the Queen side knight c6 developing a
knight and now here White has two
alternatives they have Bishop c4 or they
have castles we're gonna be focusing on
Bishop to c4 so we can understand the
main ideas for both sides Bishop d7
continuing to develop Castle queenside
and here whenever both sides Castle on
opposite sides of the board we have
White King on the Queen side we have the
black King on the Kings side both sides
are gonna be rushing to push their pawns
to attack the enemies King we're gonna
try and break down their fortresses
we're gonna play rook c8 and then
Sicilian this is a very common idea we
want to put a rook on c8 to take control
of an open C file Bishop b3 is a little
bit of prophylactic prophylaxis against
Knight e5 because we don't want to move
this bishop with temp but we can just
move it right away 95 now we're gonna go
ahead with the idea of pushing pawns to
break down the fortress
h4 black is gonna play Knight c4 he's
gonna trade his knight for one of
White's bishops so if Y allows it he's
going to take on e3 but why it's
actually gonna take on c4 with the
bishop we're gonna take on c4 with the
rook we don't want to move the Queen we
have a nice little battery coming down
here with the Queen and Bishop here
white is going to go with a pawn
sacrifice this is actually a big theme
in the Yugoslavs
we can sacrifice a pawn to open up the H
file the Knights gonna take we don't
want to ruin our pawn structure and then
White's gonna play g4 and attack the
knight so we have to move it back to f6
and here now we see White has an open H
file he's trying to attack now black has
a very common sacrifice that we're about
to see in a couple moves why is the play
h6 and trying try
off this dragon bishop they say this
bishop and the dragon is very very
important for black and sometimes can be
considered worth the value of a rook
which is five points black is going to
go and take on e4 with the knight and
this might seem strange at first because
it looks like we're just taking upon and
if they take our knight then it looks
like we just gave up a knight but we
actually had this move rook takes d4
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves we can actually recover pretty
nicely after rook takes check and here
both sides are doing fine now let's say
they move the Queen or common move you
might see is queen to h2 but this lets
black kind of win after Bishop e5 our
queen is being attacked so the best move
is Queen to e3 just so that way there's
no tempos off the Queen and the common
sacrifice for black is rook takes on c3
this is a positional sacrifice after B
takes c3 a very common move is Queen to
a5 trying to come in and break in on a
White's Queen side and if they take with
the Queen then while the Queen hangs so
they can't do that but B takes c3 our
knight is under attack so you have to
move back to f6 and now we see why it
has this attack on the Kings side coming
towards this King Black is gonna try and
attack on White's Queen side and this is
kind of where the middle game begins we
exit out of the opening so this is the
Yugoslav attack again the key features
is going to be black sacrificing on c3
for position and it's going to be a
hyper aggressive game with both sides
trying to checkmate each other so that
is the Sicilian defense dragon variation
in the Yugoslav attack
[Music]